in the last few months North Carolina
has become a Haven for abortion access
in the South it is one of the few States
in that region that hasn't restricted it
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade in June abortion is legal in North
Carolina up to 20 weeks of pregnancy in
neighboring South Carolina a ban
starting at six weeks has been
temporarily blocked CBS News got
exclusive access inside a clinic in
Raleigh where a flood of patients is
coming from out of state Caitlin Huey
Burns shows us how this trend could
affect key political contests in
November
watch me Kelly Flynn runs a woman's
Choice clinic in Raleigh which has been
flooded with calls we were at like 1500
calls a week an hour up to like 2500
calls a week from patients coming from
out of state before The Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade roughly 35 percent
of patients treated at this Clinic were
from out of state now with most
neighboring states restricting or
Banning abortion the clinic says that
number stands at 56 percent now we just
helped a patient from Alabama last week
they drove a 10 and a half hour trip to
make sure they were at the clinic at
nine o'clock that morning 10 and a half
hours each way and that is typical now
yep and so that we have patients here
today that came from Florida and one
came from Georgia and they have to drive
back today it's an issue resonating with
Democratic voters I have friends who are
opening their doors to people in border
states who can't have a safe and legal
procedure
um and you just pray they it doesn't
happen here but it's definitely a real
possibility if people don't not vote the
fate of abortion access here in North
Carolina all depends on what happens in
the legislature Republicans have a
majority there but they don't yet have
enough seats to override a veto from the
Democratic governor that could all
change after November's elections in
North Carolina's tight U.S Senate race
Democratic nominee Sherry Beasley hopes
the stakes will drive voter turnout you
know it certainly is very important
Caitlyn I can certainly tell you that
that even in the smallest rural
communities
regardless of party affiliation people
want to talk about abortion access and
I'm going to work and I'm going to vote
to stop inflation but Beasley's opponent
congressman Ted Budd who supports
Federal abortion restrictions believes
the election will hinge on the economy
and his supporters agree we need our gas
prices down we need our grocery prices
down North Carolina Republican pollster
Paul Schumer maker says there's little
upside for GOP candidates like Bud to
engage on the issue of abortion keep the
discussion about the economy don't have
the discussion about the abortion issue
because quite frankly he runs a risk of
of stepping on his base enthusiasm for
turning out for CBS mornings I'm Caitlin
Huey Burns Raleigh North Carolina
Burns thank you